- LATER, BROS.
DRIVE SAFE.
JUST KIDDING.
- HEY, MAN, WE'RE GONNA BOUNCE
OVER TO JEFF ROSS' PLACE.
HE'S GOING
TO LET US MILK HIM.
BUT SERIOUSLY,
THANKS FOR EVERYTHING.
- GREAT SET.
WISH I WAS INVITED!
NEXT TIME,
OR WHATEVER.
LADY TROOPERS!
MOUNT UP!
VERY GOOD.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
THIS PLACE
LOOKS FANTASTIC.
EVEN CLEANER THAN
WHEN THE PARTY STARTED.
THAT'S WHY I MADE YOU BADGES
MADE OF TRASH.
THERE YOU GO,
MY LITTLE TRASH QUEENS.
TRASH QUEEN.
WHAT'S UP WITH YOUR FACES?
WHY ARE THEY SO SAD?
- WELL, WE HAD FUN,
MR. DEVINE.
- PLEASE, MR. ADAM...
DEVINE.
- WELL, WE HAD FUN,
MR. ADAM DEVINE,
BUT WE KIND OF WANTED
TO TRY BEER.
- YOU'RE TEN YEARS OLD.
AND YOU'VE NEVER
TRIED BEER?
[rap music]
- ♪ LET'S PARTY
WITH A BAD GIRL ♪
♪ PARTY IN THE N.O.
WITH A CUTE GIRL ♪
♪ WHERE THEY AT
WHERE THEY AT ♪
♪ WHERE THEY AT NOW
♪ I NEED BAD GIRL
WHO KNOWS SHE'S CUTE ♪
♪ WHEN I PUT HER
ON THE TEAM ♪
♪ SHE KNOW
HOW TO SHOOT ♪
♪ TAKING SHOT
AFTER SHOT ♪
♪ GETTIN'
WHITE-GIRL WASTED ♪
♪ BEAT A CHICK DOWN
EVEN WHEN SHE FADED ♪
♪ UGH, LOOK AT
LOOK AT HER GO ♪
♪ LOOK AT THAT BOOTY
ALL ON THE FLOOR ♪
♪ HEADLINING
BALL LIKE A PRO ♪
♪ GET YOUR MAN
TAKE HIM HOME ♪
♪ DO IT ALL
ON THE FLOOR ♪
♪ WARDO,
WAIT A MINUTE ♪
♪ THERE GOES
MY FAVORITE BAD GIRL ♪
♪ LIKE A DEVIL SINNING
♪ SHE'S HOT
AS HELL ON FIRE ♪
♪ MY GIRL'S OLD NEWS
AND YOU'RE MY NEW HIRE ♪